so a couple months ago i was
interviewing people getting their
thoughts on 9 11. and while doing an
interview a man on my right was
screaming and hollering telling us that
we didn't know what we were talking
about so we decided to interview him and
as it turns out he was a homeless
veteran suffering from ptsd so this
interview gets pretty intense so brace
for impact with that being said let's
talk ptsd
you can you can have your turn
about marines
when you want to give your two cents
about marines thank you for that have
you ever fought for this country bro the
founder of our company has never fought
for this country have you have you ever
been in a platoon and limbs are blown
off tell us what it's like then you come
here and then you see all this [ __ ]
no one has respect
no one has morals no one has principles
and they want me to act normal
you know what i saw sir tell me sir
please tell me
i saw my platoon a little girl that we
used to feed candy to
pull a cord
and blow off limbs
where was this
kuwait wow when were you there 92.
tell the people at home that don't know
what you're talking about what they
should understand homeless vet
i have no dvd 14
i have a
it hurts me to say that please share
your story we're listening it hates me
to say this
but i have an honorable discharge
because when that little girl pulled
that cord
i went
and i started student everybody wow this
was during the persian gulf war when was
it 91
92. so tell us what it's like being a
marine a veteran now being homeless what
does it feel like what should people
understand i'm homeless i have money
okay
but i can't live in the house no more
why is that because i have ptsd okay and
the walls shortened down and i got to
hang out with right people and how do
you get help for something like that sir
i drink a lot of alcohol okay does that
cure does that just take away the pain
for the short term what does that do the
marijuana helps too it always helps i
agree with that you know marijuana and
my anxiety problems yes i'd rather smoke
than drink and i'm not no way trying to
be disrespectful no you're being very
respectful thank you
i just hope
i just hope in my heart yes sir you want
to feel this feel this
what's in your heart sir what is that i
felt something no twist it i know i
don't want to do that but what what is
it what is it once you twist it okay
it's a pacemaker yes sir you see the
bulge that i got wow the crosses yes sir
i like it out here i don't get as much
as i'm supposed to okay and i'm just
i'm basically killing myself out here
like it killed myself being inside the
military wow what would you say to
military vets watching this that are
just coming home from afghanistan right
now
i'm here for you
why there's a lot of military veterans
that are calling the suicide hotlines
it's the phones are ringing more than
ever what would you want to tell the
veterans of why they should not commit
suicide and what do they have to live
for
you know what helped me with my ptsd
what's that it's hanging out the beach
cool man
cool you making friends what is it and
getting into
you know there's a lot of programs out
here but we're scared to talk to people
because we don't want to hear the same
[ __ ] that we already saw
well that's quite frankly why we want to
talk to guys like you because your story
is crazy compelling there's going to be
people watching this tearing up i know
you're tearing up and because it's real
out there is it not i lost my wife to
breast cancer i'm so sorry man how long
were you married 10 kids i knew my wife
since junior high school
10 kids
four of them died two sets of 20 wow
that's insane you want to know what
character in the bible i am tell me
job
why is that
because i've lost everything and i'm
trying to get it back
how do you get something like that back
[Music]
you have to have faith italiano with all
this and thank you so much for sharing
do you still love america yes
why throughout all this and all the pain
if i didn't have this pacemaker in my
chest i'd still be fighting for this
country
is there something you would want to fix
about america
hunger
hunger
okay you're a military veteran would you
would you sum it all up and look in the
camera and tell the people exactly what
they should know about you and what it's
like to be part of the military
may i say something to all you young
kids out there
if you guys are out there at 17 trying
to sell drugs and all that
join a military group and help me
because
it kept me safe
but if you guys don't you're all going
to lose your life
you guys got to get a good perspective
on your life
because if not
you end up over here point
over here
you're going to end up over there
getting drunk with some kind of girl
thinking that you're all that
the point of the matter is
[Music]
the point is
america is still fine to fight for it
and i would still do it
even though i'm getting jacked right now
i would still do it
italiano thank you so much for your
service
thank you for being reasonable and thank
you for doing this interview it's much
appreciated
thank you
stay blessed not stressed
awesome and and and
teach people to be grateful not hateful
that's awesome you know just on a
personal note i've done maybe 10 000
interviews this probably is my favorite
interview i've ever done so thank you
for your time
i'm glad god let me into your your heart
thank you respect
salute
wow that was powerful
if you or someone you know is struggling
with mental health please call
1-800-273-talk
or visit ptsd.va.gov
for more information